in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Judy's
here
hi Judy how are you hello how are you
better than I deserve welcome welcome
good to have you so where do you live
from Houston Texas very cool and here to
do a debt-free screen yes all the way to
Nashville how much do you pay off about
fifty eight thousand dollars very cool
and how long did that take you about
four years the last two years and five
months was most of it at forty four
thousand a year income our for forty
four thousand in the last two years of
debt paid off all right Wow yeah you
killed it that's very good
making what kind of money um I have some
colleagues listening but I recently had
a promotion most of it was in the 30s
and then I had a significant promotion
about that okay yes okay thirty plush
we'll call it all right very good
good for you Wow congratulations what
kind of debt was the 58,000 so furniture
set living room for an interest set also
I had a car which is funny because when
I bought the car on the way home the
Baker Street your theme song came on and
I thought oh Dave's yelling at me it was
a good decision but anyhow so um how
much was the car debt the card debt
actually was only eleven thousand one
hundred forty dollars that I paid off in
one month past my goal of eighteen
months okay I was nineteen and the rest
of it was student loans very cool so
what happened two years ago that caused
us to go into overdrive well I want a
dog and it's just me I'm by myself I
want a dog and the kind of dog that I
want a German Shepherd can't live in an
apartment so I need to put myself in a
position to where I can be in a house
and have the dog you know roam free and
that was an incredible Drive so okay so
I need a house so that I can get a dog
yes okay that'll make you go and then
how did you get connected to us let's
see um essentially through a co-worker
many many years ago I would listen to
your programs on you know my lunch
and so forth and then I'm just a big
believer I I refer to you as my
financial dad I've been to two of your
money Total Money Makeover events and to
your smart conferences great awesome
times Wow
and yeah I just about bought all the
books in here already oh my god so I'm
definitely a Dave Ramsey fan you know
all the way if you need any help with
speakers you have colleagues listening
yeah Wow
well congratulations amazing very cool
stuff so what was the key to you being
able to pull this off to getting out of
that to paying off fifty eight thousand
dollars worth of that focus and
determination growing up I learned how
to be creative and resourceful and that
coming from a meager you know beginnings
really helped put things into overdrive
I thought you know if I didn't have it
then I don't need it now you know but
now it's my choice to do without
and so now I'm buying you know little
trinkets and I have a clothing budget
and it's kind of neat um anyhow so yeah
focus and dedication throughout this
whole journey I'd like to say that I had
at different times up to five jobs at
the same time that was an interesting
conversation with my niece she thought
that I just kept getting fired I no no
no that's not the that's not the
principle I'm trying to show you so just
taking different opportunities and so
forth and what was the worst job you had
oh goodness that was a I was actually
recently it was a production assistant
job for an event it was a one-time and
it was grueling work 7:30 in the morning
all the way to 1 at a.m. the next
morning so it was sometimes the folks
aren't nice and sometimes the folks
aren't nice but you know that's ok
because now I get to be here with you so
and and everyone here and everyone out
there listening just keep at it keep
keep doing it cuz uh it'll come very
cool very cool congratulations thank you
so you're single yeah so what was the
hardest part of this yeah so doing
all by myself I had some accountability
partners they're a great group of
friends two different couples so they
would help every now and then but no
really it was just you talk about it all
the time as far as determining defining
your want and you know now right right
now I'm kind of defining my new carrot
so follow so I've been checking out the
house websites and it's still you know a
couple years off but it's it's what are
you willing to work for and and that
that's what pulled me through yeah you
set that goal out there that carrot out
there in front of you keeps you moving
absolutely I'm single or married it
keeps you got if something that keeps
you moving towards it that's very very
true and something real quick I'm so
sorry but something that I asked when
your production PA teams earlier it
would be great if you had like singles
events but you know anyhow principle
it's the same principles whether you're
single or whether you're married they
don't change it still get out of debt
get on a budget still the same thing
it's just the the good news is you don't
have anybody you have to talk into this
the bad news is you don't have anybody
yell at you if you don't do it right so
I mean it's that's the it's a different
dynamic in that regard but but the rest
of it the other than the dynamics are
the same so well very cool
well congratulations very very proud of
you alright Judy from Houston Texas
fifty eight thousand dollars paid off in
four years forty four that in the last
two making thirty plus thousand a year
single lady count it down let's hear a
debt free scream three two one
way to go kiddo
well done well done